il a fait faire une séance de voyage de
voyance un petit peu spécial on va
démarrer benjamin castaldi maxime et
kelly regardez en fait ils pensent que
c'est une secte séance de voyance
normale et à la fin ils se rendent
compte que c'est encore un coup de barre
regardez
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur bonjour savez-vous juin
c'est bien même si comme moi jean et qui
a des racines d'accord qui sert d'hôtel
même beaucoup de chefs toujours un peu
d'appréhension de quoi l'écosystème
autour afin petit exercice pour vous
détendre d'accord donc cette étape est
dans vos mains
allez-y j'ai frotté et dire oui oui on
tape dans les mains
est ce qu'il ya une star quels thèmes
connus et qui voulait rentrer en contact
avec quelqu'un est décédée bonjour
précédent à savoir excuse-moi battre et
simone signoret à part de ces deux
grosses stars pardon c'est donc là ils
m'ont tant au choix vous avez donc de
deux tables et le choix du roi ce que
moi j'ai une star en vue mais c'est
plutôt une star américaine qui est
décédé moi je vais tuer charlot à côté
de vous jure je ferais charlie chaplin
qui essayent de rentrer en contact avec
vous ou le qu'on parle de quoi
et j'aimerais vraiment savoir s'il
marrant parc d'attractions qui va
s'appliquer légende
parce que j'aimerais beaucoup mais je
vous jure que je plaisante pas monsieur
je suis sincère on va taper dans les
mains s'il vous plaît
on tape dans les mains on frotte et
après on dit oui à la frapper
soit on dit oui très fort oui oui oui
alors maintenant je vais établir votre
rapport avec les éléments à chaque fois
je crois de cartes
vous allez dire très fort j'aime ce que
vous allez voir
détendez vous
[Musique]
l'ajam le feu j'aime ça vous vous en
voyez
j'aime l'eau
[Musique]
j'aime me taire j'aime ma terre
si vous aimez les faire tourner je vais
mourir
j'aime la terre plus fort j'aime la
terre
[Musique]
si j'y vais pas il faut le garder
pendant 50 ans non je ne parle même pas
la terre moi j'ai besoin d'entendre
j'aime la terre voilà on dit le plus
fort qui n'aiment pas la terre des âmes
l'acsta c'est rien c'est mon pantalon et
qui fait du cash
je savais que c'était un piège est amer
merci alain minc attali que lui et
machines